bonjour à tous Je me présente je
m'appelle Stina je suis compositeur et
producteur membre de raisin musique je
fais de la musique depuis maintenant 10
ans à peu près et la raison pour
laquelle j'ai choisi de devenir sur TEDx
aujourd'hui c'était pour vous parler des
choix et de son importance
je pense que ce qui nous définit
aujourd'hui c'est ce sont nos choix
clairement autant les choix imposés que
ce qu'on peut choisir de faire
directement et aujourd'hui j'aimerais
vous parler de ça en musique je l'espère
et pour rebondir par rapport à ça pour
vous parler de moi moi je suis d'origine
comorienne j'ai grandi au Comores
jusqu'à mes 15 ans ça c'est quelque
chose que je n'ai pas choisi et
[Musique]
en rapport avec la musique mon père
était musicien j'ai malheureusement pas
grandi avec lui et on pourrait dire que
la fibre musicale elle met un peu venue
comme ça parce que on pourrait on
pourrait croire qu'elle vient de mon
père etc mais avec le temps je réalise
que il y a énormément d'autres
paramètres qui ont fait que j'ai fini
dans la musique
par exemple aussi le fait que ma maison
aux Comores elle était située à côté
d'une boîte de nuit et que tous les
week-ends je subissais en quelque sorte
la musique qui était jouée là-bas que ce
soit le rap le tombolo
toutes les musiques africaines les
musiques européennes qui venaient à
l'époque aux Comores ou également le
compas le zouk etc donc ça veut dire que
durant toute mon enfance j'ai toujours
été percé par la musique que ce soit
directement ou indirectement et
ça c'est on va dire ça fait partie des
choses qui me sont qui ont été imposées
à ma vie et mais c'est réellement c'est
réellement à l'âge de 8-9 ans que j'ai
décidé de faire de la musique
et que j'ai commencé à apprendre des
cours je demandais à ma mère de de me
trouver un professeur de percussion donc
j'ai commencé à bosser avec Ignace qui
lui m'a donné le rythme en fait il m'a
appris à construire des rythmes etc et
après ça ma mère elle m'a elle m'a
demandé si je voulais prendre des cours
de solfège et c'est quelque chose que
moi j'avais refusé donc pour ceux qui
connaissent pas le seul fait c'est tout
ce qui concerne la théorie musicale et
c'est quelque chose que je n'ai pas
voulu faire à l'époque et c'est un choix
que j'ai fait et que je regrette jusqu'à
aujourd'hui parce que je ne connais pas
la musique jusqu'à aujourd'hui
malheureusement mais ça ne m'a pas
empêché de
de dépasser justement
cette non connaissance on va dire pour
apprendre d'une autre manière et être
autodidacte dans mon domaine
donc pour illustrer les percussions je
vais vous jouer une boucle que j'ai
préparé
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qu'un choix
je pense qu'on peut définir le choix
sous différents aspects premièrement
l'action de choisir ça veut dire que tu
peux décider de croire ou ne pas croire
en quelque chose tu peux décider de
faire ou de ne pas faire quelque chose
tu peux décider de dire ou de ne pas
dire quelque chose et ça c'est propre à
toi et ça va forcément découler sur des
conséquences il y a le fait d'avoir des
options
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui tu peux être
confronté à quelque chose dans ta vie et
avoir différentes options car ce chemin
là le chemin là le chemin là et c'est à
toi de choisir et forcément le choix que
tu feras impactera sur la suite état
celui qui est le plus
le plus le plus difficile à comprendre
du moins c'est les choix imposés comme
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure tu vis
dans un certain pays tu grandis dans un
certain environnement et en fonction de
ça ça on va dire que ça conditionne ta
manière de voir les choses ou de
surpasser ou non ou de d'affronter
certaines épreuves de la vie etc et pour
illustrer ces choix là je vais vous
parler de deux oncles à moi donc il y a
Nihad et à Faouzi
c'est un oncle à moi avec lequel j'ai
grandi que je considère un peu comme mon
grand frère et qui depuis petit en fait
il me fait écouter énormément de musique
ça veut dire qu'il avait sa pochette de
céder avec une centaine de CD et il me
faisait découvrir tout ce qu'il écoutait
à l'âge de 10-11 ans j'ai découvert une
émission de rap qui s'appelait le code
qui leur show où il y avait DJ Cut
Killer qui est mixait et c'est la
première fois que j'étais confronté à ça
et ça m'a énormément marqué de voir que
tu pouvais mélanger des sons et c'est
réellement un stage là que je me suis
dit que j'allais finir ma vie dans la
musique je ne savais juste pas dans quoi
mais à cette époque là je sais que je
voulais DJ
donc en rentrant au coma
j'avais aucun outil pour pouvoir
du moins m'exercer dans cet art là ou du
moins essayer de le comprendre et c'est
là où je demande à Faouzi mon deuxième
oncle
de m'acheter un logiciel de DJ il se
trouve que pas aussi il se trompe et il
m'achète un logiciel de beatmaking
donc
ça fait partie des choix imposés on va
dire parce que on aurait été en France
ou dans un autre pays j'aurais eu le
choix de
repartir en boutique échanger le CD
prendre mon logiciel de DJ et de rentrer
chez moi chose qui était impossible
comment parce que justement on était
loin de tout on n'a pas tous les outils
nécessaires justement pour travailler
dans ce qu'on voudrait faire surtout
dans dans la musique
donc c'est un choix qui m'a été imposé
et que j'ai subi en quelque sorte et vu
que j'avais ça ben j'ai fait que ça il
se trouve que sur le logiciel j'avais
uniquement la possibilité de créer des
rythmiques et les boucles de mélodie
étaient déjà prêtes donc j'avais juste à
choisir les bouts que j'aimais bien et à
créer ma propre rythmique
et pour illustrer ça je vais vous
montrer
ce que ça a découlé et du moins ce que
ça m'a aidé à faire
[Musique]
arrivé à la fin de mon lycée justement
arrive forcément le moment où on doit
choisir sa vie
vous imaginez bien que en tant que
comorien ça a été très compliqué pour
mes parents pour ma famille de
d'accepter que je décide de faire de la
musique mon métier parce que vous
connaissez vos parents c'était c'est
quelque chose qui est très difficile à
envisager pour eux parce que
parce que malheureusement au Comores il
y a pas eu énormément d'exemples de
grosses grosses grosses réussites au
niveau musical
donc pour eux c'était c'était un avenir
on va dire incertain et mais j'ai quand
même cru
j'ai quand même cru et j'ai fait le
nécessaire il a fallu que je fasse
beaucoup plus notamment pour les
convaincre eux mais pour me convaincre
moi que je faisais pas un mauvais choix
en
me lançant dans la musique de manière
professionnelle et c'est justement après
ça que je me retrouve au Sénégal parce
que ma mère travaillait là-bas et que et
que ça faisait un long moment où
justement j'avais pas vécu avec elle par
rapport à son travail et que là elle
avait souhaité à ce qu'on vive ensemble
je m'inscris dans une école de son
là-bas
et je commence à vivre ma vie de
comorien à Dakar
en tant que compositeur donc je fais la
rencontre de pas mal de gens là-bas je
rencontre des journalistes des artistes
etc qui avec qui j'essaye de collaborer
avec qui j'essaie de faire de me faire
un nom et je me rends compte que c'est
que c'est super compliqué parce que le
Sénégal est un pays qui est très
conservateur si je peux dire et donc ça
a été difficile c'est ça a toujours été
difficile pour les étrangers de se faire
une place dans un pays comme ça et donc
ça veut dire que des fois je me
retrouvais dans des dans des studios
avec des artistes où je faisais écouter
des musiques à moi ou me calculait même
pas et c'était très difficile à vivre de
c'était une période assez compliquée
pour moi aussi mais qui a énormément
changé ma vie parce que justement
le fait de se faire de voir les portes
se fermer au niveau des artistes au
niveau des des journalistes etc ou même
du milieu de la musique
ça m'a ça m'a forgé ça m'a pas ça m'a
pas fait perdre espoir au contraire et
ça m'a donné envie de développer encore
plus
cette branche musicale que j'avais en
moi et
grâce à Dieu j'ai fait la rencontre de
différents artistes comme jet-sen comme
comme search comme Moula etc qui sont
qui étaient là-bas donc là et qui lui
est sénégalais mais jet-sen et sœurs qui
sont Comoriens et et qui avait enfin que
j'estimais avoir
enfin je trouvais qu'ils avaient
énormément de talent et c'est des gens
qui m'ont permis
de développer mon art et et à qui j'ai
pu développer leur art aussi donc au
final tout ça pour dire que malgré tous
les coups durs il y a énormément eu de
choses positives et ce qui comptait pour
moi c'était que malgré les personnes qui
qui m'embolicoté qui m'ont qui m'ont
comment dire qui m'ont tourné le dos qui
qui m'ont estimé etc pour moi ce qui
comptait c'était le produit final ça
veut dire que je savais que je faisais
de la musique et que je le faisais pas à
petite échelle et que peu importe les
épreuves qui avaient devant moi ce qui
comptait c'était le résultat ça veut
dire que
que je devais exceller dans tout ce que
je faisais peu importe qui j'avais
devant moi
[Musique]
les choix que j'ai pu faire dans ma vie
ils ont été faits en fonction du temps
et de l'espace
et
avec du recul je remarque que il y a pas
eu de bon ou de mauvais choix il y avait
juste des décisions à prendre ou à ne
pas prendre
et quand je décide de prolonger mes
études et de m'inscrire dans une école
sur Paris qui forme au métier de la
musique
c'est une école en fait qui forme
justement toute la partie business de la
musique et j'estime que justement après
ces deux années au Sénégal où j'apprends
justement tout le côté technique
il me manque justement la partie
business de la chose donc de fil en
aiguille je me retrouve à produire
différents artistes notamment Joe que
qui était mon premier placement à
l'époque où je fais quasiment en 2014
de là en fait
il y a des choses qui se présentent à
moi donc des propositions de signatures
et et
je prends la décision de ne pas accepter
parce que parce que c'est des choses
enfin je me reconnaissais pas dans ce
qui dans ce qu'on me proposait et comme
j'avançais encore avec toute l'équipe
donc il y a des et washi dont je vous ai
parlé au début il y avait uniquement des
propositions pour moi alors que moi je
voyais justement le la vision plus
grosse où je voulais justement que rise
and shine existe en tant quantité et pas
juste en tant que style NAS donc je
prends la décision de ne pas signer de
ne pas accepter certaines certaines
propositions de Deal etc et
il y a une anecdote qui qui est super
importante pour moi parce que il y a un
titre justement que je fais que je
propose à dinos
qui lui le kiff de ouf justement il
était sur la préparation de l'album de
son album et c'était un morceau qui
s'appelle plaque diplomatique qui en
fuite avec avec Joe justement et
durant la préparation sur l'album il
fait ce titre et il décide de le sortir
mais pas sur son album et uniquement sur
des plateformes de téléchargement
gratuites et pour moi à l'époque
justement le son que j'ai fait pour lui
c'était une de mes meilleures prod donc
j'estimais que que le titre méritait de
finir sur sur une plateforme
que ce soit Spotify iTunes ou Deezer et
pas juste sur un truc gratuit ou les
gens allaient l'écouter etc
sans justement sans justement être
vivant être mis en valeur et dinos il
insiste pour qu'on sorte le morceau et
au début j'ai été très réticent par
rapport à ça et il insiste tellement
qu'au final je me dis on va disparaît je
me dis que j'en ferai un autre etc c'est
une période durant laquelle malgré tout
le travail que je fais je ne gagne pas
encore ma vie avec la musique ça veut
dire que je subis toujours
la pression de ma mère et de ma famille
concernant le travail que je fais
malgré les heures de studio que je passe
enfin malgré les heures de studio que je
passe
où je suis enfin que je fais en dehors
en dehors de l'école toutes ces heures
que je passe en dehors de chez moi
des nuits limites de enchaînement de
nuit blanche ou justement je ne fais que
travailler mais je ne vois pas le
résultat je suis seul dans ma tête à me
dire que je sais que ce travail là va
forcément payer et c'est pas tout le
monde qui arrive à de concevoir et à le
comprendre et
ce qui se passe c'est que le choix que
je fais de sortir le morceau de dinos
enfin le fait que j'accepte de qu'on
sorte
qui me rend triste etc et ben ça ça a
ouvert les portes sur autre chose dans
le sens où il y a un producteur qui
s'appelle Spike Miller
qui lui m'appelle après avoir écouté ce
morceau et qui me dit on a énormément
qui fait le travail que tu as fait
dessus est-ce que tu voudrais venir
bosser avec nous sur l'album d'Alonzo
donc forcément je dis oui et c'est un
truc où je m'imagine pas enfin je me
serais jamais imaginé qu'en faisant ce
choix là ça m'ouvrirait les portes de ce
travail là sur cet album là avec cet
artiste là qui a l'époque fait partie
des plus gros en France et donc je
saisis l'opportunité bien évidemment et
on fait différents titres avec lui dont
deux qui se retrouvent dans l'album et
il se trouve que c'est les deux morceaux
qui
qui qui marque en fait la cassure entre
la période où je travaille sans gagner
d'argent et la période où je commence
justement à vivre de ma musique et
tout ça pour vous dire que c'est quand
même un choix que j'ai fait avec
énormément de regrets qui m'a ouvert les
portes sur autre chose et en fait je me
rends compte à ce moment-là que la
raison pour laquelle j'ai travaillé tout
ce temps là
sans être payé ou à être mal payé etc ou
toutes ces heures de studio en fait
elles ont payé elles ont elles ont servi
à quelque chose parce que c'est à mon
service justement à développer toutes
ces palettes musicales à travailler ma
manière de faire ma manière de voir la
musique etc et c'est ce qui m'a tous ces
outils en fait ils m'ont permis de
justement arriver à ces deux disques de
platine sur un album et à carrément
changer ma vie en fait
et
le morceau que je suis en train de vous
faire écouter il marque aussi ce travail
là dans le sens où
à travers les différents voyages à
travers les différents les différentes
personnes que j'ai pu rencontrer les
différents échecs les différentes
souffrances les différentes réussites
aussi minime qui a pu s'être elles ont
forgé la musique que je suis et la
personne que je suis aussi
[Musique]
comme je l'ai dit souvent la victoire
aime l'effort
c'est une phrase que je me dis souvent
et que je me dis que quand on veut
réussir quelque chose
plus c'est gros et plus il y aura des
sacrifices à faire
et la raison pour laquelle j'ai voulu
parler des choix c'est aussi parler des
sacrifices que j'ai pu faire dans ma vie
ça veut dire que j'essaie d'illustrer
différentes périodes de ma vie les choix
qui m'ont été imposés à travers mes
différents voyages et la seule chose
qu'il faut retenir c'est
qu'est-ce que tu fais face à certaines
situations et comment tu vas transcender
ta personne pour y arriver peu importe
d'où tu viens j'aimerais juste que à
travers justement toutes les épreuves ou
que j'ai pu traverser que tu puisses
déjà t'identifier que tu saches que je
suis passé par des choses pareil par
lesquelles tu es passé aussi et j'irai
le plus loin possible pour marquer
justement un point
et de te dire que le point qui a été
fixé là-bas c'est un mec comme moi qui
l'a fait ou c'est une femme comme moi
qui l'a fait et que si lui il a pu y
arriver je peux y arriver aussi et je
pourrais même le dépasser
[Musique]
des billets des billets de 100e ils ont
les mains plein de sang
va monter un bises en tournant comme
dessive chercher ma paix comme des mois
des mais pas de peine pour nous voilà on
va te faire cabaner
je viens de la zone je fais que du sale
je promène dans cette nuit à Moroni je
prends mon Tmax